es gibt ja die gibt es gar nicht wenn
der große moschee fan ich bin ein über
50 jähriger mann und für schicke mode
ist es außerdem sehr zweifelhaft ich
erschrecke selber werde ich wieder so
ein lacher oder irgendwen küsschen oder
so was für schicke und das hat was damit
zu tun dass ich in mode ist eigentlich
für die modernen hieroglyphen halt also
ich glaube ich habe mir sogar vorstellen
können dass eine moschee sprache und
schrift an die stelle unsere schrift
wird sowie unsere schrift an die stelle
der glyphen getreten ist alte ägypter
ihr wisst haben irgendwie tolle bilder
die aber eine sprache waren in die wände
gezeichnet und gekratzt aller moment und
achtung jetzt was dann aber jetzt bricht
meine ehe gestern und zusammen denn für
meine idee ist es ja wichtig das image
ist etwas mit der wirklichkeit zu tun
haben ich bin traurig ich freue mich ich
bin verliebt ich sehe eher schlechte
laune ich übergebe mich einer erkennt
ist aber jetzt gibt es definitiv einen
schwangeren man das ist jetzt also
sozusagen der neue motor sind denn ein
schwangerer mann außer in einem fall an
den ich mich in ein wissenschaftliches
sensation gab es gibt es gibt glaube ich
also habt ihr schon mal schwanger ich
habe heute morgen etwas versteht es gab
tatsächlich weltweit 14 wird es um nach
einer gebärmutter transplantation
ok also aber es ist und ich sah aus als
sei ich schwanger weil ich als meine
frau schwanger war aus solidarität zehn
kilo zugenommen als baby einen
ernsthaften gedanken noch dazu das gibt
jetzt die also vor dass man selbst die
größten unsinnigkeiten oder
absonderlichkeiten für real halten soll
ich finde es den den schrangen man gibt
es dann übrigens auch als schwangere
person das sind mann dahinten zwischen
euch auch als schwere person so dass man
sich kaum mehr festlegen muss ob der
mann oder die frau schwanger ist also
dieser komplette wir geraten komplett
durcheinander mit unserer wer sind wir
was wollen wir warum sind wir da etwas
machen wir miteinander hat einen neuen
höhepunkt mit dem schwangeren mann und
ich frag mich wann soll man eigentlich
einen schwangeren man verschickt also
ist es mir glauben ich verwende viel
gegessen hast aber kerstin verstehe aber
dass patricia wäre doch genau jetzt
waren wir einmal das wäre doch dann eine
veräppelung von schwangeren frauen wenn
man einen fetten wir bräuchten man damit
trotzdem will mit dem schwanger man
verwöhnt man eigentlich die schwangere
frau und an der stelle finde ich kommt
der punkt wo man sagen muss weg mit dem
schwangeren man man sieht es hier noch
mal also man kann auch nicht sagen
wirklich food baby ich habe niemanden
bisher gesehen wer nach dem essen
plötzlich natürlich form aus der ist es
so gegangen wie gesagt zehn kilo es gibt
den formvollendeten natürlich sozusagen
nicht nur als weiße sondern als einen
weltbürger in allen ausgestaltungen
absolut toll aber die sache selber ist
völlig irre
welches ist eines der motive am meisten
benutzt es gibt dir selbst das spiel
dann ist man auf dem handy meine schau
zeigt
leider ist es nur so eine art
wunschvorstellung ich glaube es ist
wirklich langweilig erweise der daumen
hoch daumen hoch für haye gut gemacht
ich habe mir schon bei mir ist es dieses
erstaunte gesicht dieses nicht schlecht
eigentlich immer vielleicht nicht bei
mir ist der achter mit den augen davor
weil ich immer auf falsche tastendrücke
jetzt muss ich ganz kurz 1 machen wir
sozusagen in eigener sache ja doch ich
verschicke auch herzchen
nicht dass es vermisst wird
der sonos geschickt mit herzchen haben
wir das glück währt wunderbar also das
sind die neuen die muttis man muss dazu
sagen es dauert noch eine weile 37 sind
insgesamt die hier kommen sollen da ist
ganz viel dabei ich freue mich zum
beispiel über eine discokugel also es
sind auch sachen dabei die man
vielleicht mehr benutzen kann in party
stimmung ist es google da gibt es aber
bei diesen diesen tanzenden man gibt es
ja schon sehr genau da gibt es in tänzer
schon als gast oder ausweis ich muss
sagen bei den hinteren da komme ich erst
ein also und ich komme zurück zu meiner
neuen sprache
discokugel herzchen champagner
schwangerer mann das ist doch irgendwie
eine fast sinnvolle reise könnte es
passieren die neue wirklichkeit hinein
wirklich
[Musik]